[Music]
so
we had basically two different
applications
again we had one that was for them to be
able to upload their information that
was due at 2pm every wednesday it was
basically
like hospitals local health departments
long-term care facilities high red pre-k
through 12. so
they've created these different customer
entities if you will
they have a template an excel template
we pulled out a whole bunch of stuff
that they used to have to fill out
because we could automate it for them
um so we really pared that down to just
get the essential information that we
needed from them
and created this interface for them to
be able to upload their file
then we save it on the back end and name
it and we create a whole bunch of new
variables
with the data that they upload at the
time the only restrictions we really
checked for were you know making sure
that fields that were required actually
had information in them
some of them had to be structured a
certain way things like that but we
didn't necessarily
have anything else that we were checking
for um what we built in later on and
where the process now starts is
when the group at the gyadaf which is
the joint area
interagency task force that's the group
of groups if you will
within our state that's overseeing all
of this when they find out
what the supply is going to be coming in
in the next week from the cdc
they can go into this tab and they can
allocate
a certain number this is they do it all
in vials but a certain number of files
for each
entity so for hospitals they're only
allowed a maximum
of a hundred modern vials they'll put
that in here
visor and j they're doing it for all
three brands
right now a vaccine and so now when they
go to
upload their information we're checking
against that if they upload it as the
draft
it won't prevent them from uploading but
it will give them a message like a
caution message to say
you're over your max allocation so you
need to fix this before
uploading your final version and then
they can go in and sell and select final
and upload their final version and then
that's really what's used
then to create the final distribution
report for the week
um so this is kind of a checks and
balances system to make sure
that they're not having to go back to
these people afterwards and say you've
asked for too much
or to break any hearts later on to say
you asked for too much we're only giving
you this amount like it's very
transparent this way they know how much
they're
they're allowed to request for the week
so once that's done again by
2 pm on wednesdays we go back over here
this is our vaccine demand management
application and this is where the bulk
of work
does happen they have another tab where
they're then able to go
and download the final distribution
report
and i should save final loosely so it's
the distribution report
that's generated based on what was
uploaded
by the customer entity groups then we
also have an overall vaccine request
you can see over here too this is a good
check for them
they're all working together in a large
armory so
technically all of these different
people that are using the system
at least the two we've talked about so
far they're on wednesday afternoons
they're all in the same room
but it could be a little walk to go get
to them so this just makes it easier
they don't have to get up and go ask the
person hey have you uploaded your
information it's all right here and they
can see
which groups have already uploaded which
which haven't you know they can create
the reports and download those
so from here we have a request summary
that will summarize the total number of
vials
that need to go to each distribution hub
we have our upload status of when the
different entities last uploaded
and then this just aggregates all of the
information
that came from the different requesters
you know the different customers so it
just
you know compiles all the different csv
files
into one and then here we have the
distribution report so
this we're generating a tab for every
um hub to work from and
then this this sixth tab i'm not gonna
go into that today but it's uh
it's similar information about ancillary
kit inventory
so not only are they tracking the
vaccine inventory at the different hub
locations
we also have to make sure that we have
syringes and needles and alcohol pads
and gloves and all of that fun stuff
to go with the the vials of vaccine
to be administered we automated all of
this
we have some business rules where we're
assigning the day
of pickup and the time of pickup for the
different groups
um again this is mock data that we used
so um everybody is requesting one vile
vaccine but it has county information
it would have a point of contact name
and phone number you know if they're
late to their pickup but didn't
communicate anything
to the distribution hub they can easily
get a hold of the person
from here there is still an annual
process involved and we can't get rid of
all of them
but our contacts the national guard
they'll go in
and they will look at what was requested
and as long as
you know there are no concerns about
supply you know as long as
demand is met by the supply they'll go
ahead and confirm that that is in fact
what they're going to be allotted for
that
that following week so they can go in
here if they need to and make
adjustments
in the allotted vials in a lot of doses
section if they need to
and we also create a column for
delivered doses delivered vials
but really every all the inputs we have
them do are in vials and then we take
care of the math on the back end to say
how many doses are in each file and when
we take care of that
once they have all of that finalized for
the week
um they can there's a separate app where
only like
two people have access to upload the
final version of the distribution report
again centrally they can add new work
orders if they need to if a special
request comes in they're like
okay yeah we have extra supply on hand
we can accommodate that
they have a fee they have a tab where
they can input that information
and it automatically updates the
distribution report
they can also do change of orders so if
somebody needs additional vials they can
just add it to a certain work order
instead of creating a whole new one for
that same customer
so we gave them those features to be
able to do that
and while they're making their changes
on this
end we also allow the hubs they're able
to go into their own application
where they're tracking pickups so on
this first
tab they'll enter the work order number
they can look it up to make sure they
actually input it correctly
um and the total number of vials that
were picked up that day
then they also can change pick up times
or pick up days of the week if they need
to
and this is just a way for management to
know
if something wasn't picked up why it's
because they changed their pickup time
that's fine
and then download distro report they can
download an up-to-date version if they
want to but also in this data table view
they can just scroll through or search
for anything in their particular hub so
at any point in time the hubs are able
to download the most up-to-date version
of the distribution report
as well as management in their um
vaccine demand management
application all of it is as real time as
we can make it and again we're working
with people who
are used to working in excel anyway so
we wanted to make sure to keep that
sort of feature intact for them